the One Piece manga just showed us
exactly why the sunod Nika's abilities
are absolutely broken because as we see
at the end of chapter 1,11 bunny reveals
a completely new power that allowed her
to actually imitate Na's rubber Fist and
boy did that leave this miserable
government agent completely knocked out
and really all of this has got me
thinking that if Bonnie's attack was so
insanely powerful just by imitating NAA
then Luffy's Na's abilities are 100 %
the most game-changing abilities in the
story which of course makes sense for
our main character to have but let's
break down what makes them just so
ridiculously powerful and what we
actually know about NAA at this point in
the story and first of course there is
the actual rubbery stretchy abilities
that everyone has discussed many many
times now but to see it being used by
someone else other than Luffy was just
really mindblowing I mean do keep in
mind here that Bonnie was basically just
a regular child at this point she didn't
have any any special lineage or training
that made her extra strong well I guess
you could argue about the lineage but
the fact that this partial NAA
transformation without knowing what they
actually look like allowed her to take
out a full-blown government agent is
just incredible but beyond even that
though it is the versatility of these
powers that truly make them so strong
because Luffy and now I guess somewhat
for Bonnie they can adapt the powers to
whatever they need in order to overcome
a battle and honestly before we even get
into all of the insane implications of
this here can we just pause here for a
moment and be grateful for how amazing a
story Oda just keeps delivering every
single year and the last few weeks and
months in particular like literally
could you think of a better Christmas
present for your friends and family than
the first volume of one piece and if
you're now thinking that Manu no way
that my girlfriend Linda will be happy
if I give her a manga for Christmas well
then first off I think you should break
up with Linda right now but if you
really want a similarly fantastic
present for her then I got you covered
here as well because this video is
sponsored by the style king of sponsors
on YouTube holzkern now for the few
uninitiated amongst you who don't know
holzkern is the company that makes all
of the Fantastic jewelry and watches
that I pretty much always wear in my
videos like this necklace this bracelet
or this watch which in fact turned me
from a true watch hater into a true
watch believer and honestly I think it
will do the same for Linda and all your
other friends and family like let's say
I had to rank the three one piece
characters with the most drip in the
story D Flamingo kizaru Blackbeard of
course well you can be just as cool as
them with these highquality accessories
made from these beautiful natural
materials like actual wood and stone and
I'm not kidding when I say that 95 of
all accessories that I personally own
are actually by holzkern and I have
given their stuff as presents to friends
and family before so if you need the
perfect Christmas present with quick and
free shipping worldwide well you can use
my special code Ohara 15 for 15% of your
entire order and while you're at it
throw in the latest chap of One Piece as
well because I mean how Wild is this
chapter please but actually on top of
all that there is another part of Na's
abilities that just really stood out to
me which is the power of belief because
we've now seen all throughout the story
that Luffy and more recently NAA really
end up bringing hope to those who were
about to give up and who are basically
enslaved and tyrannized by others really
you can think back to almost any Arc in
all of One Piece and Luffy is always the
one who brought hope and freed people
from suffering and then bringing this
back to the current storyline it was
Kuma's belief in NAA from a very young
age that actually ended up helping him
never giving up his surge for freedom
and also a cure for Bonnie and so
honestly it was just incredibly awesome
and kind of surprising to see that when
Bonnie needed to escape from the person
keeping her hostage she thought of NAA
and those Powers ended up helping her
Escape but honestly it goes even further
than that because at this point I'm
really starting to truly believe that
NAA was basically a God that the
Buccaneers and even many other races in
the one piece World actually used to
worship now if you look really into it
there are actually signs pointing to
sunod Nika being a major religious
figure all throughout the story that was
erased by the world government at some
point and in case you haven't seen these
examples I can just point out this sun
logo here that appears in many many
important places such as this cross
recently in Kuma's Church the Fishman
Sun pirate symbol the kuki crest the
alabasta flag and even in skypia in
shandur and really the one thing that
ties all of these people and all of
these different places together as you
know is the relationship that they have
to the ancient Kingdom and so at this
point since we do know that NAA at least
in the form of Joy boy was a major
figure for the ancient Kingdom I'm
really starting to think that NAA might
either have been the founder of the
ancient Kingdom many thousands of years
ago or even a literal God that many of
the ancient Kingdom allies actually
started to worship which would very much
explain how the Buccaneers religion
started as well and that has somewhat
carried on to this very day and actually
while we're talking about religion right
here it's actually important to bring up
that I kind of wonder if mihawk here
actually was a former holy which has
been speculated a lot on Twitter before
who was eventually then converted to
this new NAA religion yeah does sound
crazy I know but there are a ton of
connections when you think about it
between mihawk and emu's Throne that
people have pointed out such as the
markings on the empty Throne being very
similar to the markings on mihawk swords
and actually the empty Throne is modeled
after the actual Imperial Throne of
Japan which does have these two lions as
well but also this chrysanthum type of
logo which does actually appear on
mihawk's shoulder as well and on top of
that mihawk's eyes are of course also
eerily similar to that of emus but you
might now be wondering how all of this
makes sense in terms of him believing in
NAA now and the answer to that is mostly
based on his character design because
clearly he has this whole Christianity
Vibe going on which I've discussed in a
lot of detail in previous videos in fact
his cross necklace kind of reminds me a
lot of the cross that Kuma had in his
church back in the sorbet Kingdom or I
mean look at the pattern of his handle
of his sword yodu and if mihawk does
actually believe in NAA then it would
also explain why he let good Pirates
like Luffy and Zoro survive when he so
easily could have killed all of them
plus of course if Shanks told him about
Luffy and Shanks knows about the truth
of the naika fruit it would make sense
that mihawk also knows the truth about
Luffy B NAA and thus kind of sparing his
life now I just had to bring that up
here because it was just so cool to see
Bonnie's NAA powers and honestly this
new power might be one of the most
broken abilities these in the entire
story like seriously when you think
about it just by believing in this new
future Bonnie can literally transform
her entire body which doesn't really
make any sense trust me I know so let's
break down how this power works and the
game changing side effects that it could
have on the end of the ekad island art
because this power is called distorted
future and when Bonnie uses it she can
transform part or all of her body into
something entirely different than her
regular self we actually first see her
used this power back in chapter 1072
when she became this super buff version
of herself and now that we have a better
understanding of how this power works it
does seem that Bonnie was imagining
herself in the future as a Buccaneer or
maybe just some super strong fighter and
this power made it come true which is
just a mindboggling power to have but it
gets even crazier in this chapter
because when Bonnie was about to be
recaptured by the world government she
remembered that na had a rubbery body
which allowed her to somehow imagine
herself as NAC and literally transform
herself into a giant gear five version
to throw a massive punch I mean what how
is that even possible so just to clarify
at this point it does seem that as long
as Bonnie can imagine herself becoming
something in the future even if there is
no real way that that would possibly
happen then she can actually transform
herself in the present which when you
first think about it you might be like
yeah that's cool and all but it's not
amazing but if you're thinking that stop
right now thinking that because this
power could be the key to changing the
entire one piece World literally and
believe me listen to all the ways that
this single ability could change the end
of ekad islands for one let's start off
with Bonnie herself because when we
first saw her on ekad island she was
about to be executed by a bunch of
marine gunfire however with her
distorted future Powers she could simply
turn her body back back into a rubbery
na form just like what we saw in this
chapter which means that just like Luffy
this new rubbery body should allow
Bonnie to bounce back all types of
bullets so I do know that we're all
expecting Kuma to show up and save the
day here or Dragon but Bonnie may not
even need him in order to save herself
here in fact let's not stop there
because what if Bonnie imagined a future
where she was the strongest swordsman in
the world let's say could she then just
take one of Zoro swords and starts
slicing up Saturn as if she was mihawk
but really that's just the start of this
because next let's imagine that Bonnie
can also use this power on other people
except herself and I mean why not really
because she can after all use her
regular abilities to make people older
or younger or even use this power on
Vega Punk to turn him into a baby so
let's assume for a moment that she can
actually use distorted future on other
people as well as we know Luffy was
exhausted lying on the ground but what
if Bonnie imagines a future where Luffy
is completely healed or a future where
kizaru is actually an ally instead of an
enemy or a future where Saturn was so
old that he literally turns to dust see
what I'm getting at here now surely
there will be some sort of restriction
on what she's actually able to do but
the possibilities are just so fun to
think about and honestly I do think that
it would be incredibly powerful if
Bonnie was the one in the end who saved
herself and everyone else instead of
Kuma here I mean sure Kuma has been the
tragic hero of the entire flashback but
just imagine how great it would be if
Bonnie didn't need his protection
anymore and instead she's the one who's
actually able to save him instead and
what better way to do that than to
imagine a future where Kuma never lost
his memories which would bring her
adopted father back to his normal old
self and man I mean what I personally
wouldn't give to see this become reality
but now as incredible as that would be I
actually do wonder if Bonnie has an even
greater level to unlock using these
powers of course I'm talking about
Awakening here because something to keep
in mind about this is that this entire
time Bonnie has only had her devil fruit
for about 6 years now which is a
relatively short time to master its
powers so I think there's a really good
chance here that she hasn't even
awakened her devil fruit yet and what
other perfect opportunity could there be
for her to do so than in this really
high pressure high stakes life or death
situation on egad Island right now and I
know I know we can't just say that
without actually speculating what that
Awakening would look like so let's look
at what we actually know about paramia
type Awakenings basically every awakened
paramia so far we've seen allows the
user to use their devil fruit powers on
their environment and so with that in
mind plus our current understanding of
Bonnie's distorted future ability I
think it's fair to wonder if Awakening
Bonnie's devil fruit could allow her to
actually imagine a distorted future of
the world around her like for example a
future where egad Island was even more
technologically advanced than it already
is does sound funny but just imagining
some kind of laser cannons or something
all locked onto Saturn and Blasting him
to bits and this idea isn't all that
ridiculous when you think about it since
the world used to be even more
technologically advanced in the past
according to Vega Punk himself or if we
wanted to get really crazy yeah do it
get really crazy well what if Bonnie
could actually affect the entire world
somehow with her powers I'm just
literally picturing her imagining a
world that is not oppressed by the world
governments how cool would that be just
imagine multiple panels of people and
races all over the world living in peace
instead of poverty and slavery which I
will admit sounds just way too good to
be true because I mean then we would
basically not need Luffy anymore but
still you know it's fun to think about
the type of stuff in the end though I am
very sure that Oda will have some very
reasonable restrictions for this power
that keep it from being way too broken
as it does seem at first glance but
still since he is emphasizing it right
here it simply has to play a role now in
the climax of echad Island as well I
think and since we're speaking of
distorted Futures right now um Oda
certainly changed my opinion on Monkey D
Dragon a lot in this chapter because we
kind of learned that he was actually
keeping close track of Luffy for his
entire childhood basically that's right
everyone Dragon isn't a completely dead
beat of a father seriously it does seem
that every time that the revolutionaries
would visit the goek kingdom Dragon
would actually sneak off and stop by to
check on his son although to be fair he
very likely kept himself hidden from
everyone including Luffy and if I had to
guess this is most likely because he was
trying to protect Luffy and the
villagers from becoming a target of the
world government either that or Dragon
didn't want Luffy to be captured and
used against him in some way or form
kind of keeping his distance so people
didn't know about their connection but
either way it does seem that Dragon
actually cared a a lot more about Luffy
than we all originally thought which is
kind of nice to see for being honest
also by the way can we just all
appreciate for a moment Dragon Stone
Cold confidence when he tells Kuma that
he better stops talking about Luffy
unless he wants to die I mean wow I
we've all seen just how powerful Kuma is
during the flashback so for Dragon to
just casually threaten Kuma like that
just really shows that Dragon isn't
messing around when it comes to his son
but this dynamic between these two
father figures is also incredible L
interesting in another way because I do
wonder if Dragon situation is at all
like Kuma's here where he actually lost
the person that he loves to the world
government you know that entire line
about a child is a parents weakness just
makes me wonder a lot if Luffy's mother
somehow sacrificed herself to the world
government in order to protect Luffy and
that is exactly why Dragon eventually
left the Marines and ended up starting
the revolutionaries but bringing this
all back to Kuma here though this
chapter clearly confirmed that Kuma knew
exactly who Luffy was and was also
probably looking out for him once he
became a pirate I mean certainly their
meeting at thar wasn't the first time
that Kuma had seen Luffy which just
makes me question even more if Kuma
would have ever gone through with his
orders to kill Luffy in the first place
probably not and at this point I really
highly doubt it because it seems like
Oda has had Kuma and dragon's
relationship figured out all the way
back then already however one thing that
still confuses me a bit is why didn't
Kuma go meet Bonnie when she was
actually free and a pirate I mean sure
he did promise the goo say that he would
never see her again but there was
definitely time for him to meet with her
and then escape the world government
together I mean just think about it Kuma
at this point didn't have his memories
completely erased yet until after Marine
Forge and at that time Bonnie had been a
pirate for a few years already I mean I
guess you could speculate that the
government had already raised those
parts of Kuma's memories at that point
which makes a little sense but on the
other hand in this very chapter he was
shown to still help out the the
revolutionaries plus he has always used
his famous where would you like to go on
vacation phrase so there's got to be
some sort of memory of Bonnie still in
there somewhere and now maybe you could
say that he was worried that Bonnie
would become a slave again but come on I
mean Kuma is easily one of the strongest
Warlords and it would probably take at
least one or more Admirals even to take
him out so I definitely think that he
could have used his powers to find
Bonnie and then escape the world
government together I mean who knows
maybe we'll just find out more about
that soon but no one really can say that
Kuma abandoned Bonnie here because at
least he was trying to write her letters
however as we saw in this chapter these
letters then were tragically destroyed
by the world government agents watching
over Bonnie which really just adds to my
anger and to the tragedy that all this
time Bonnie did hear from her adopted
father and if you think about it Bonnie
has not heard from Kuma since he left
her back in their sorbet Kingdom around
2 and a half or 3 years ago from the
current story line line however if it
makes you feel a little bit better there
might be some sort of Hope for Bonnie
still reading those letters in the
future because if you look back at the
very first time that we saw Kuma send
someone away using his powers he does
look down into his Bible before sending
this ghost girl away for example and to
me that personally means that Kuma was
using the Bible to keep all of his notes
about the places he wanted to visit with
Bonnie so I can just imagine that even
if Kuma shows up in ekad island and ends
up sacrificing himself to save everyone
let's say then Bonnie will probably at
least be able to read the book that he
leaves behind and maybe visit all the
places herself in memory of her adopted
father as sad and tragic as that would
be but now let's actually swing all the
way back to the part where Bonnie
escapes at the end of this chapter which
gives us a hint possibly about one very
interesting theory about the goo and emu
because during Bonnie's plan to escape
the world government's agents we
actually find out that these agents
don't actually know that Bonnie has
devil fruit powers and if we assume that
the agents don't know about her powers
then it also makes sense that the rest
of the government wouldn't know about
them either I mean how dumb would that
be if Saturn or someone else knew about
it but then didn't tell the people
watching over Bonnie but let's assume
that they actually didn't know at all
which means that the government
certainly wasn't using Bonnie's powers
for themselves and to give you a little
bit more context on why that might be
important we have very long wondered how
the goto s emo seem to be virtually
Immortal we've always speculated that it
might be the immortality surgery using
lost fruit another really strong option
was Bonnie's AG related devil fruit
abilities as well but clearly if the
government didn't know that Bonnie even
had these powers to begin with then they
wouldn't have been using her to keep
them young as well so that just really
crosses one potential option of the list
for explaining how the goo emu appear to
have lived for centuries and really
that's just one of many super
interesting little details in this
chapter because during one of Kuma's
many many visits back to ekad Island he
also met Stussy who is Mea Punk's clone
of M Buckingham the former member of
rx's crew and what's most interesting
about this meeting is that Stussy is
basically a clone who was basically
given Humanity while Kuma is becoming a
cyborg while losing his Humanity Stussy
even goes as far as to compare the
situations and ask which one is the more
tragic and while this is really
interesting to think about by itself I
do want to bring this back to the
current situation on ekad island where
we have a ton of interesting comparisons
first of all there's obviously the saaim
who likes Stussy are actually clones
however unlike Stussy they do not seem
to have the same kind of freedom and
Humanity that she does so basically this
is just another reminder that the saaim
are going to have a super important role
to play in the future and don't be
surprised if they eventually actually
gain their own type of Freedom where
they can act off their own will instead
of being forced to follow orders but
that's not all because we have another
human who kind of has to shed his
humanity and who is virtually a slave
with Admiral kizaru and since he has
basically given himself up to just
following orders I really do Wonder if
he will have a real change of heart here
and rebel against the orders of the
government maybe Kuma showing up will
inspire him or something that Bonnie
does will change him but I just can't
help but see the similarities between
kizaru's situation and what Stussy said
in this chapter and hopefully it will
lead to the end of the world
government's rule very very soon and
even though we've already talked about
the new information that Dragon actually
kept an eye on Luffy during his
childhood and things have worked out
pretty well for Luffy with the way that
things are going right now it really
must have been hard for Dragon
nonetheless to keep himself from going
down and just taking his son and raising
him himself I mean can you just imagine
if you were a parent but had to stay
away hidden from your child seriously
talk about literal torture but have you
ever wondered what might have happened
if Dragon didn't stay away in other
words what might have happened if Luffy
was raised by dragon and if you want to
check out that video you can click right
here Shanks for watching and I will see
you in this next one